where are we motorcar diner in Central
City no I meant what here your original
life your friends your family will fade
away there's anything else to each other
but we know your string bean I went back
in time and created a whole new
existence there's a timeline out there
where I'm not rich that's a glitch in
the universe a flash season premiere
Tuesday October 4th on the CW
hey youtubers is Charlie a new flash
trailer was just like a little bit of
new footage giving us a better look at
what's going on in the first episode
when flashpoint picks up so let's break
it down so this is just a little bit
different than the last trailer that
they posted but it's for the first
episode
you noticed that Barrie jumps back to
his street the same way he has like the
same look on his face when the
reverse-flash first came back and was
like Gideon where the hell am I just
looking for where he was in time like
everything looks different I don't
understand and then you Barth on starts
narrating all of your old memories your
former life that will start to fade away
just explaining how the new memories are
going to take their place because of
flashpoint and then you see his father
or what looks like his father telling
him this is the motor-car diner so what
I think is happening is is this is Jay
Garrick because he's like what time is
it
he almost thinks that he's come to a
different time in history so in addition
to Jay Garrick showing up in the first
couple of episodes yeah you know Jay
Garrick's back I think that the diner is
going to replace jitters is like a new
set that they use that they go to every
once in a while like you know they would
go to jitters
and they talk there'd be like some funny
scene sometimes they'd bump into people
like old and glad or like oh my god what
the hell are you doing here while we're
getting coffee so it's just a new
standing set but there is a diner from
the flash comics that they go to every
once in a while like sometimes you see
the Rogues there there's this diner that
you see Johnny quick talking to old iris
West enduring this avatar story from the
Mark Waid comics you know I've been
talking about that recently that story
line iris West during that period was an
older person she'd already had children
they'd had grandchildren Bart Allen
who's Barry and irises grandson had
already come back in time you have to
remember that this was after Wally West
had become the main version to the flash
it was after crisis on Infinite Earths
so everyone had believed that Barry was
dead so classic 50s diners very
important to the flash comics so it just
seems like in the way that TV shows
season to season try to refresh things
use new sets the diner is replacing
jitters maybe there will be a flash
themed dish like they had the flash
coffee that they would sell people with
like two extra shots of espresso in it
maybe they'll have like a flash meal
that's like a burger or something like
that but you also get a little bit
better shot of
Matar here with his speed Cole looks
very much like his temple it's really
like a castle in the comics but I don't
think there's gonna be a castle on the
flash so I think it's gonna be like some
underground lair you see some pipes here
we still don't know who's avatar is on
the TV show they've explained that the
rival is being played by this guy from
Vampire Diaries so we know who he is but
as of a couple weeks ago they had not
cast this avatar character for a while
they did that with the zoom character
last year where you didn't know his
identity they just waited a little bit
longer to actually cast the actor they
cast Tony Todd to be his voice but Teddy
Sears like the actual actor to
physically stand on camera in the
costume wasn't cast until a little bit
later so really I think the bigger
takeaway from this footage is that we're
actually going to get to see Barry come
back to the future after he saves his
mother and noticed that everything's
different
and then they'll jump forward three
months in the timeline because Grant
Gustin said something really interesting
around comic-con
he's like Barry's been in this new
timeline for about three months just
getting to know his family that he's
saved his mother and his father but when
the trailer started dropping he was
running into iris and she's like hey you
know do we know each other oh you're
that Barry Allen guy and then later you
see a scene with him in STAR Labs where
she's like hey you know we're like
something more to each other aren't we
but Candice Patton said that in the new
timeline like as of where things pick up
she and Barry have only gone to school
together so she just barely knows him
she's like oh you're that guy that was
in you know all my classes hey you know
how's it going we also know that Wally
West is a version of Kid Flash so they
don't really address it in these
trailers here but I'm curious to see if
when Barry first comes back to the
flashpoint timeline and notices things
are different he bumps into Wally West
and is like oh my god Wally you're
wearing a flash costume WTF oh my god
you're a version of the flash now
because there's no way that like three
months goes by without him noticing that
there's another flash in Central City
that just happens to be one of his
friends like oh my god there's another
flash and it's Wally this is awesome but
whatever way they logically chose to
explain Wally getting his Speed Force
powers and Barry learning about that
that'll all be dealt with in that
first episode that's what there's so
much stuff that they have to do in that
first episode that they said that Tom
Cavanagh has character and Jesse quick
aren't coming back right away remember
what happened at the beginning of season
2 like Barry came and like we found out
what had happened Barry been on his own
for a couple months we got like a little
teaser for doppelgangers we thought that
Harrison wells that you Bart dawn
Harrison wells was dead so like whoa
we're never gonna see him again but then
they learned about the breaches we got
the really big breach beneath STAR Labs
and then guess who appears at the end of
that second episode it's Harrison wells
from earth-2 so I'll be willing to bet
that at least Harrison wells if not just
a quick as well will show up at least by
the end of the second episode of this
season they just like Game of Thrones
you know crazy cable HBO show do not
make you wait that long to find out
whether or not someone's dead or coming
back so let me know in the comments when
do you think that Tom Cavanagh and Jesse
quick aren't gonna show up again do you
think it'll be the exact same deal and
it'll be by like the end of the second
episode when they're like fully back in
the third episode I think even if it's
just a little bit longer they're not
gonna make us wait that long even if
when they first come back Jesse quick
does not have like her full costume on
it'll probably be like an episode or two
before we see her in a comic book
costume we get hype and congratulations
to the giveaway winner Jace little you
win a copy of the flash season 2 blu-ray
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details and there's a new round
of the giveaway that starts now like
I'll keep doing it till the flash comes
back so next because they just confirmed
Joe Manganiello as Deathstroke for
Justice League I'll probably do a video
for that next there's also like a bit of
a Justice League video with them
standing together supporting a political
cause so I might include that too
so more Justice League coming later
tonight get hype is gonna be awesome
what you guys wait for that to post you
can click here to watch that Deathstroke
teaser again and you can click here to
learn all about sabotage backstory in
the flash comics thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight